Join us join us mightiest heroes not today, sir
Are you making your voice deeper you know on April 27 summer begins be mocking me. He's trying to copy me
Confident he wore a smash-and-grab heist film you know it's Thanos his
intent on collecting the Infinity stones
And it's gonna move quickly to do it because he knows
When word gets out that he's trying to collect the Infinity stones that the forces of the universe are going to line up against him
So he's got a ticking clock
And that that's kind of the essence of the film
It's a very simple plot after Avengers 3 and 4 Marvel Studios will begin a new phase in its universe
Do you feel like you as directors of some of the biggest movies of the studio?
Have reached the end of a cycle - I mean
Look we love working with Marvel. We love it. Yeah
We didn't we prioritize the quality of our experience with the quality of the work
And and Marvel it's always been both areas have been of the highest. He could possibly
Want to desire so we've had an amazing experience working with them
You know they've been so focused on these movies though that we haven't been thinking beyond them
We'll say though that that Fox deal goes through with Disney
There's a lot a lot more characters to work with us and be interesting to do something like Secret Wars
Wait a minute Secret Wars
What did he just say look at the face on his brother when he says that word like he just smiling like oh?
Yeah, something's coming down the pipeline. I will address the Disney Foxx deal, but there's so much New Avengers stuff to break down
Love the tease for forces of the universe so that's where he's talking about Celestials
He's talking about the elders of the universe the larger cosmic entities moving against Thanos
So I'll address all those people in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Because we've mostly been focusing on the Avengers in the guardians teaming up to fight Thanos
So if you're finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway -
Recently the trades reported that Fox had been talking to their people about the Disney deal like hey
You're not gonna lose your jobs. This is what's gonna happen
Conservative estimate they said the dust is gonna settle on everything in Kevin Feige
We'll get to do whatever he wants to with those Fox characters at the end of next summer 2019
That doesn't confirm that they're gonna add any post-credit scenes or anything like that to Avengers 4
They could work in verbal references
They could do things at the last minute if they know that the deal is going to close
But they can't really cross those characters over unless Kevin Feige makes an arrangement with Fox before the deal closes
Because until the deal closes all of the power in making that decision where those characters appear still rests with the Fox people it doesn't
Really revert to Disney until ink is dry on paper in what the Fox people are telling their
Employees is that that's going to be done at the end of the summer 2019 that could happen faster
It could happen later, but they also reveal some details about the technicalities
They said that the Fox people are basically gonna stay in their studio space right now Disney's gonna lease that for the next seven years
but for the most part
It's about what you'd expect like they'll just get access to that IP so whatever their plans are for
Avengers five they can totally do secret Wars
Which is why you know you see one of the Russos here sort of smiling into camera as the other ones like yeah?
You know Secret Wars now?
I think that kind of crossover is the easiest prediction to make everybody's been thinking about that but the Russos
Themselves are done with Avengers films after infinity war they're not totally done with Marvel
But it does sound like they're gonna go and do something else for a couple years before they come back so whoever does the next
Avengers film will be somebody else but talking about the Celestials
They're the big cosmic people in the Marvel Universe if they were a big part of the comic book Infinity Gauntlet story
What's going on with them in the movie universe, but it just sounds like from the way, they talked about it
They didn't actually write the Celestials as characters into the movie
They might get referenced Peter quill referenced eternity
Which is probably the biggest concept that Marvel has ever teased next to the multiverse which opens a whole host of possibilities
But when they say that the forces of the universe will find out what the Annis is doing and move to stop him they're also
Talking about the Watchers the most powerful cosmic beings that we've met so far
I don't really include Dormammu in that because he's not from our universe he's from the Dark Dimension
But I think they're also teasing a lot of stuff that will appear during Avengers 4 that
We'll see for the first time during the Captain Marvel movie like we've never met the Skrulls
There's whole areas of the universe that we'd never traveled to before Thor Ragnarok
Was the good example of that like literally the end of the universe where all the trash gets dumped?
So if during this guardians of the galaxy sequence you see them
Bouncing through all these different space portals to go to different areas in the universe
James Gunn has teased that we're gonna meet a lot of those people in the next 10 years in the movies
There'll be like a bunch of new cosmic movies that they haven't really talked about yet
Because I think it's still in the early planning stage because I do think we're gonna meet more Celestials
We'll probably get more into like the grand concepts
Seriously think about it this way if James Gunn did a talking planet?
Then think about what he's going to do when they get really crazy in phase 4 and whatever phase 5 is
Going to be
biggest prediction for those new big space-based movies is that they eventually work up to an ultimate team-up movie
Which you know could either include Captain Marvel or some of the other new characters if you're not familiar with that title
Ultimates is like a comic book line that Marvel did the ultimate universe?
But it's also the name of a team-up that Black Panther funds that mostly deals with big cosmic
Concepts whereas like the Avengers deal with more identifiable villains like they fight Thanos they fight the other like
physical beings The Ultimates deal with problems like
Galactus the super flow if you're not familiar with the super flow is that's sort of like this space outside of reality where cosmic concepts
Communicate with each other do not be surprised in the next 10 years if you see them introduced blue Marvel
Spectrum America Chavez America Chavez is probably a little bit easier to do blue Marvel
But I wouldn't be surprised if they use Captain Marvel is sort of the go-between
Character that does space-based movies sometimes and does earth-based movies sometimes because they're always going to be the Avengers cross
Those will still be relatively earth-based. They'll go into outer space when they cycle the guardians roster
They'll still be a relatively space-based movie
So they're just a couple easy
Crossover characters that have one foot in both of those areas that you could serve as like a point of connective tissue
Between whatever this new cosmic universe is gonna be in like the traditional Marvel Universe like you see in spider-man movies
I know everybody's pushing for Galactus will know something's up if the Marvel people like Kevin Feige James Gunn come to comic-con
2019 for their Marvel panel to announce whatever is happening next and they're wearing x-men t-shirts, they'll be the ultimate teaser
They wouldn't even need to tell you what they're doing just show up wearing x-men paraphernalia, and that'll let you know
Oh, we're getting ready for a crossover
There was a lot of other Hawkeye that they talked about a lot of like the missing characters secret characters like Peter Dinklage
So I'll do a video for that soon leave all your infinity war video requests in the comments below
And I'll name a new giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
But click here to watch Thanos use the Infinity Gauntlet and click here for that funny behind-the-scenes video
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight